well the MIT student in music or in the
arts in general is normally a volunteer
that is in the many things that they
have to choose from in terms of their
education at MIT they're going to put
their energies into the thing that they
think is going to give them the most
both satisfaction broaden their
experience and so forth so that their
commitment is freely offered so we find
at least I found always that very seldom
at MIT do I need to make a case for why
they're there they're very good at music
mainly because they're very very
intelligent extremely powerful logical
thinking or interest in structure or
curiosity about how things are made is a
really good ingredient for someone start
studying music at any level or producing
music or or performing music and that's
something that an MIT student almost is
is guaranteed to present
student studies music one of the most
important things about the encounter is
that it won't yield to final results or
or objective evaluation the way so much
of what they operate in can it won't
even be subject to fairly consistent
judgment as there won't be a whole level
of agreement about whether something is
valid and one things I've discovered
after years of teaching the most
important thing is for us to indicate
enthusiasm to to if we are very Minh to
something we have to let that be known
because they entering the study of the
arts need that kind of conviction to
believe that with all these
uncertainties that it's worthwhile
students have changed a lot over the
years partly because the culture has
changed and moved towards MIT so
radically I mean when I first started at
MIT the very clearly MIT oriented
student had rather exceptional interests
and background it was a highly
specialized set of interests that
brought people to MIT having to do with
early interest in the computer
tremendous scientific concentration a
kind of centering of the edge of the
educational interest on science and
maths of worth since then secondary
education in this country has moved
radically in that direction
so that a typical good student in high
school or preparatory school is an MIT
student you know and so an MIT student
who shows up here is quite clearly to
somebody like me who's been here a long
time a much more socially comfortable
broadly interested athletic arts
oriented typical student who might be
anywhere but he's somebody that MIT
wants to accept in other words
culturally the skills that are required
to even take it to undertake an MIT
education are much more widely
distributed for the same token there's
probably many many schools that that
compete for a student with MIT that
wouldn't have been competing with MIT
25 30 years ago
needs to struggle to maintain a balance
between its I think it's natural
hospitality to to trying whatever is new
which I think it needs to maintain very
much so with what I'd call some way of
communicating really quite broadly
optical values and fundamentals but I
think that's a repeating story in the
arts is that there's always a impulse
let's just jettison all this boring
stuff that is sort of fundamental to
knowing skills but then the best artists
almost always rediscover that no my god
we need those and we're in again that
same dialogue and MIT needs to
participate in that I think it needs to
insist on first of all that obviously
whatever is going to be produced as good
is going to be different but that it's
not going to be produced without people
who know a lot of very fundamental
simple things about say in terms of
music how tones relate how we recognize
recurrence how we what sort of formal
impulses we depend on for people making
sense of something